My group is being destroyed by this $50
deck and it's so stupid.
Hello everyone. This is Jin with next
level commander and today I present to
you a wick deck designed by my friend Ty
Lit. No, not the one beefing with Kung
Fu Panda, but a even bigger douche
because his $50 deck is leaving my
professionally built full budget decks
in the dust. And again, it's so dumb,
but it's a blast to play and the real
cost is actually closer to zero than 50
cuz most of the cards here are just
draft chaff he's been picking up and
cards he already owns. And I would never
say this to his face, but it's actually
really freaking clever. It happens to be
another perfect example of the commander
centric philosophy where the entire deck
is built around this one legendary
creature and leans on it for resource
accumulation, answering opponents
threats, finishing the game, or ideally
all the above.
This can lead to really interesting deck
building challenges and every deck
having a unique play style determined by
the commander. In our case, we have
Wick, the World Mind. And you can see
Wick covers a pretty solid chunk of what
wins games. The first line here is a
trap. Okay, we still do need it, but in
this deck we have zero rats. I mean, I'm
not saying it's wrong to play rats
tribal, but it's just it's a sweet deck,
but I don't think Wick is close to being
the best legend for that. What Wick is
best for is throwing beefed up snails at
opponents over and over until they're
dead. And that's what we're doing here.
The first thing you do when
brainstorming any commander centric deck
is looking at its weaknesses. Wick can
kill opponents and draw a ridiculous
amount of cards and generally when we
have draw power, there's just one
bottleneck, mana. So, we're starting
with all the ramp we can find for under
$2. Not too sure about the signets here.
I mean, why is Rakdos $3? This can be
any other two mana rock really, but
aside from this worth mentioning is the
cursed mirror. This one is absolutely
worth spending the big money's on. It's
a mana rock that will often come with a
sweet ETB or attack trigger. And also
it's great for resetting the snail token
after we sacrifice it. Having this come
in as a copy of Wick will immediately
get us a 2/2 snail at the cost of the
artifact of course. Bender's water skin
is a brilliant card in any deck that
wants to protect its commander. What
would normally be turn six Wick plus
protection becomes turn four. And
finally, a hidden gem in Fer Dock Court.
Becoming a 4/4 snail in a pinch isn't
amazing, but can definitely dig us out
of some snail-less situations. Now with
the boring stuff out of the way, it's
big snail time. All these pump spells
that got wheeled to you in those random
drafts are given another chance to
shine. My favorite ones are these that
give plus three for one mana and the
best among them is wild right. I mean,
you can usually cast this and harmonize
it immediately for just two mana giving
plus six. Just watch out for the sorcery
speed timing which means you will have
to do your entire signing dance during
your turn. Aside from the straight pump,
we also sprinkle in a few cards like
behind the mask to slightly alleviate
our over dependence on red mana. Just
keep in mind that these effects don't
stack with each other and avoid the ones
that can change the creature type.
Except our Lorehold All-Star, Wings of
Velis Vel, which can turn any creature,
even our commander, into a snail for
that one last kamikaze mission. Water
Wings is also a personal favorite
doubling as a pump spell or a protection
spell. And what's nice about a deck like
this is that you don't need to exact
cards. As long as you understand the
reasoning behind our choices, there are
probably tons of alternatives with
similar effects. Aside from the pump
spells, we have a few equipments.
They're often less efficient, but can be
recurring value for our mid game and
onwards. These ones that attach upon
entering are pretty similar to the pump
spells, except we are trading one power
for reusability. Bespoke Battle-Garb is
nice because we can deploy it before
Wick and it will automatically attach
once we have Wick come in along with his
favorite snail of the week. And the same
will happen every time we blink or reuse
Wick. Well, that's convenient. Cranial
plating is another really clever
inclusion. It may not be the most
efficient early game, but it can easily
pump for five to 10 power as we deploy
our mana rocks and other equipments.
Improvised Arsenal has a similar effect
with a bonus mana sinking ability that
we probably won't get to use much, but
when we do, it's going to be super
sweet. And finally, Ruin Stalker's Sight
helping anyone identify as a snail when
there's benefit on the line.
So, now we have the rocks to power out
some big snails which we will chuck at
opponents and draw a bunch. As long as
we can do that reliably, we have a game
plan. So, it's time to work on the
reliably part. Protection spells are
great. Unfortunately, this is where the
card's quality suffers a bit from the
budget restriction. The best counter
spell here is Negate, but the hexproof
cards here can do a decent job. My
favorite though are these blink spells.
They serve double duty as protection on
top of resetting the snail token once
it's used. And for that specific
purpose, we also have Crystal Shard. And
Chameleon is the only Spark Double
variant I can afford to include while
keeping that clickbaity title accurate.
And now for some spicy single utility
cards. Okay, Disciple of Bolas is just a
backup Wick, but we are spending a
whopping three American dollars on this
black instant, Tainted Strike. Yes, it's
plus one in a pinch if you target the
snail, but when it's the right time to
target Wick, you will know and it's
going to be glorious. And that isn't
even our biggest bank breaker.
Here we have at seven freaking dollars,
over 15% of our entire budget, we have
Giggling Skittershank. This is like the
single best card released for me in the
past 10 years probably. If I have to
pick one card to never use again, I'd
rather lose the One Ring than this. I
mean, just play it in any pump spell
deck in the mid game and late game, it
will just it will just end. The game
will finish. Just like that. And a
little bit about our land base. This
deck is extremely color intensive. I
mean, the Uber activation and the one
mana pump spells and protection spells.
There will be times when you straight up
find no use for colorless mana. So,
luckily in 2026, we have access to top
quality fixing on a budget. I mean,
these all used to be five to 10 dollars
a pop and I'm genuinely surprised at the
price of some of these. I'm still stuck
in the times when budget players had to
resort to them evolving wilds and guild
gates. So, pretty much everything is
dedicated to fixing here with a few
MDFCs that fit what we want to do and
there you have it, Wick's snail deck.
The play pattern can be described as
bring dead. Basically, yeah. It
That's why it's so frustrating to lose
to. I mean, my idiot friend just goes,
"Look, I have snail a pump pump attack
take 12 sacrifice it you take 12 more.
What do I do with 15 cards in my hand?"
Yeah, that's pretty much it. And now,
this is a great budget deck because
again, the core is just draft chaff, but
if we want to spoil Wick, you know, just
put in some money, there is definitely
room for improvement. Every commander
centric deck loves free protection
spells and counter spells. This will
allow us to proceed with our game plan
one or even two turns early sometimes,
which for a deck that snowballs like
this one does can be an an enormous
difference. Wick getting countered can
be devastating, so a Counter of Souls
can help patch this one weakness that
can ruin us. I mean, if there's room for
game changers, I'm sure a Demonic Tutor
or a Jeska's Will wouldn't hurt, but our
deck really don't benefit from them as
much as many others do.
Also, something like Mutavault can give
us a snail in a pinch. While the deck
slots are tight, these MDFCs can
definitely shine and it's easy to just
replace a basic land.
But again, this isn't a deck that needs
a lot of budget to function and even the
$50 version can easily hold its own on
bracket three tables. So, please let me
know what you think. Is there anything
I'm missing from this deck list? I know
that I haven't looked too much into
rats. I don't think there any rats that
synergize with what we're doing too
well, but there might be some. I've seen
arguments for Torian Mauler, but with
our current list, I don't think it's
necessary, but it's also I think it's
also probably decent, so you can try
that.
Anything else? Yeah, I think that's it.
If you're interested in more decks like
this one, please subscribe for more and
I will see you around.
See you.